Modern robots are very precise machines. They
can be used for example to place chips onto
circuit boards with great precision and at very great speed. But how do they actually do that?
The position of the robot’s end effector
is never directly measured. What we do instead
is measure the various joint angles and we
use a forward kinematic model to determine
the position of the robot’s end effector.
We assume that we know the position in Cartesian
coordinates of where the robot’s tool tip
needs to go and then it’s a simple matter
of designing a controller that takes the tool
tip from where it is to where it needs to
go. And this is the fundamental principle
underpinning all modern robots today. They
are incredibly precise, they have got very
accurate sensors, they’ve got very good
kinematic models, and they are able to move
the tool tip where it needs to go in the workplace.
Lets consider now what can go wrong with this
approach to robot tool positioning.
Firstly; because the position of the tool
is computed from joint sensors and kinematic
models, if there are errors in any of the
sensors, if there’s an error in the kinematic
model, or perhaps there is an error in where
we think the base of the robot is, then the
position of the robot tool tip is going to
be in error.
Perhaps there is an error in the location
of the chip relative to the board, or perhaps
there is an error in the position of the board
with respect to the robot’s coordinate frame.
Finally there could be an error in the motion
control system. It’s not able to drive the
robot tool tip to where it needs to go to.
Nevertheless, over the long history of manufacturing robots theses problems have largely been ironed out.
There is a consequence for this traditional
approach to robot positioning. For a start
we need to have very very accurate sensors
on each of the joints. The robot links need
to be very very accurately machined so they
reflect the kinematic model embedded in the
software. The robot links also need to be
very stiff so that as the robot changes its
configuration the links don’t bend and deform
under the influence of gravity. To make them
stiff we have to use a lot of metal, which
makes them heavy. In order for the robot then
to move quickly we need to have much more
powerful motors.
All of these issues drive up the cost of the
modern precise industrial robot.
So lets assume we have a robot and that it is really precise. How do we actually put it to use?
For the robot to do useful things the object that it’s working with — its work piece
— must also be precisely positioned. If
the robot is able to go to position x,y,z
within a small fraction of a millimetre, then
the object that it’s working with also needs
to be positioned with that same level of accuracy.
When a robot is installed in a factory a large
amount of engineering is involved in creating
what we call jigs and fixtures. These are
pieces of equipment that hold the robot’s
work piece at a very precise location in the
robot’s workspace. So when the robot uses
its precision to reach to a particular coordinate
the thing that it needs to work with is there.
Next issue is that the robot needs to know
the position of the object within its workspace.
We need to measure that very very accurately.
In practice what happens is the work piece
is held at a very consistent location in the
workspace and we manually adjust the robot’s
tool tip position to achieve the task. In
this particular picture the operator doing
this. The operator is holding in his hand
what’s called a teach pendant. It’s a
large box covered in buttons, and by pushing
these buttons he is able to drive the robot’s
tool tip to the required location within the
workspace.
An alternative to this approach which relies
totally on the inherent precision of the robot,
is to have the robot use its sensors — for
instance cameras which mimic the function
of our eyes — in order to guide it to perform
the task. And that’s exactly what we do;
if I want to pick up this stapler I use my
eyes to guide my hand so that the distance
between my fingertips and the stapler become
zero. Similarly if I want to perform a task
like putting a key into a lock, I again use
my eyes to guide my hand so that the tip of
the key enters the barrel of the lock.
Here’s an example of this in practice. This
is some work from my own PHD research way
back in 1993. Here the robot arm is programmed
to move upwards and downwards at constant
velocity, but the horizontal motion of the
robot is controlled by the shape of the line
that it is observing. So in this sense the
robot is reacting to what is in the world.
So I can put any shaped line in front of the
robot, and the robot arm would move and trace
a path along that line.
In this more complex example, the robot is
carrying a camera, and it’s trying to keep
an object in the centre of its field of view.
Now the object is on a turntable so it’s
moving in quite a complex way. In fact it’s
not moving at a constant velocity, it is accelerating,
and here we see the robot capturing the object,
locking onto it, and holding it in the centre
of its field of view.
The same technique was then applied to tracking
a ping-pong ball, which has been thrown in
from one side of the scene, and this is in
slow motion. Eventually the robot notices
the ping-pong ball, locks onto it, and starts
to move the camera in such a way as to keep
the ping-pong ball closer to the centre of
the scene. So it’s tracking the ping-pong
ball as it is moving through space. And here
it is in real time. We see the ping-pong ball
moves very very quickly.
Here is some more old work when I was looking
at controlling a mobile robot using the sense
of vision. So this particular robot has got
an omni-directional camera on the top, and
in that omni-directional camera view we can
find the edges of the roadway. It’s a very
distinct boundary between the bright concrete
road and the green grass and the brown dirt
on either side of the road. What we want to
do then is to keep the robot so it’s moving
midway between the two boundaries of the road
that we are able to observe visually.
Here is another example involving a mobile
robot. In this case the robot is using its
visual information — again from an omni-directional
camera — to position itself with a fixed
pose offset with respect to the traffic cone.
So if I pick the traffic cone up and moved
it to another place, the robot would move
in order to maintain that fixed pose with
respect to the traffic cone. So the robot
is not navigating with respect to a coordinate
frame attached to this location, it is navigating with respect to an object or a feature in its environment.
This is a vehicle, a forklift truck, and it’s
got a hook on the front, and it’s trying
to put that hook through the handle of the
crucible. There is a camera on the forklift
truck and it is looking down and using that
to identify where the handle is, and controlling
the position — the path of the vehicle — as
it approaches the crucible. In this particular
case we had to add some markers to the crucible
to help the robot vehicle achieve the reliable
pickup.
What you see now is a time-lapse movie. We
ran this experiment over a whole day. Over
the course of the day the lighting conditions
changed: clouds came and went; shadows came
and went. It showed the overall robustness
and reliability of this vision-based strategy.
The robot didn’t have any knowledge of where
the crucible was; it just moved to reduce the area between the tip of the hook and the handle.
Here’s a very similar technique, in this
case applied underwater. So this underwater
robot has got a stereo camera pair and it’s
maintaining a constant height above the seabed.